[Musique]
il reçoit toujours dans son garage de
jouer les tours Jean-Pierre Danguillaume
et sa célèbre Goye sont restés fidèles à
sa terre natale la Touraine
à l'aube du départ du Tour de France il
nous a partagé son sentiment sur
l'édition 2023
[Musique]
on dit toujours qu'il est dur le taux de
France est dur mais là cette année
tu es tout de suite dans le Pays Basque
avec les bosses et tout
et puis tu arrives dans les Pyrénées Bob
alors va falloir gérer pour pas que tu
sois trop mal au départ la beauté le
plus dedans
après tu boum tu vas arriver dans le
Beaujolais et la personne qui est on en
parle pas beaucoup l'étape du Beaujolais
t'as pas à mettre de plat
pour lui sans surprise les Français ne
feront encore pas le poids face à
pogaccharte ou vin goguard les monstres
du cyclisme moderne mais aussi face aux
armadas Jumbo est immédiate
et tout il en manque un peu
va faire un grand tour en Touraine
beaucoup ne le savent pas mais la
famille donc Guillaume la fratrie c'est
un palmarès incroyable
1800 succès et Jean-Pierre Danguillaume
en personne c'est cette prestigieuse
victoire sur le Tour de France dont un
magnifique doublet en 1974 avec le
touret et pour le lendemain
[Applaudissements]
on sait pas pourquoi quand la forme est
là et tout ça se passe bien
je montre le tourballé comme je peux je
passe à une minute une 45 je fais une
descente de balade il me passe 2
millions d'aliments
j'arrive en bas au ravitaillement les
mecs ils prennent leur musette moi
j'attaque je tombe sur trois mecs et
puis je vais les je vais les battes à
pot et je gagne deux fois le tour
d'aller mais là je fais 200 ou 300 m et
quand les journalistes
il m'arrêtent
tout le monde j'ai dit je vous parle à
condition que j'ai la une demain
[Musique]
Jean-Pierre Danguillaume et c'est un
mètre 80 aurait aimé remporté une grande
classique Milan sans Remo la Flèche
Wallonne ou encore Liège-Bastogne-Liège
il devra se contenter de Paris Bourges
en 1975 en battant ce jour-là deux
grands noms Bernard Hinault et Raymond
Poulidor
là c'est plus grand regret parce que
j'aurais pu gagner 25 ans après moi donc
je suis rejoint dans Liège
à 4 km de l'arrière je suis rejoins par
Mercedes
coureur directeur sportif puis relation
publique chez Coca-Cola Jean-Pierre
Danguillaume a participé à 42 grandes
boucles mais aujourd'hui plus question
10 pointer le bout du nez non c'est fini
l'ambiance a changé
la convivialité tout change maintenant
les mecs qui travaillent autour ont pu
une culture du cyclisme c'est des jeunes
tout marketing tout bazar et tout donc
s'il n'est plus dans la caravane il sera
bien installé dans son canapé pour
suivre France Télévisions pour une
édition 2023 encore populaire
et spectaculaire
[Musique]